Robert Strauss author of worst period
president period ever period I'll ask
you that about that in the moment I want
to read your dedication to my father
Samuel Strauss who made me read every
historical marker we've ever passed thus
assuring me of a lifetime of winning
trivia contest and my mother Edna for
teaching me out of laughs especially at
myself explain the father connection
well my dad and and it gives me this
book yeah he saw when I was little that
I would pick up the sports page and read
every little statistic on it and so he
bought me this book called facts about
the presidents it's still my favorite
book in a certain way and it was like
Moneyball for presidents it would have
every last line however long they lived
to the day after their inauguration or
you know how long their mothers lived
where they came from
anyway so it became this sort of thing
for me that I was the Moneyball guy for
presidents as a little kid and they'd
show me off at parties but then my
father wherever we drive to be some of
these historical markers right they
still exist and you know we'd have to
stop and read it whatever it was maybe
sometimes he'd make me read it aloud and
of course I played my kids the same way
so so that that of course gets you to a
Jeopardy level have thin but long at the
top while we're at it
Oh what about mom teaching at a laughs
well that's that it and that's really
important because I don't think it can
really be successful unless you can
laugh at yourself and my thought is
especially writing a book like this you
have to sort of take the opposite view
you have to sort of take the contrarians
view to say not everybody was an amazing
success not every biography has to be
about Washington Lincoln there were the
reason why I chose to do this
forget about literatures Buchanan but
why I chose to do this is I do think you
can learn
from failure I think that if the next
president wants to aspire to be like
somebody they'd probably want to aspire
to be watching their Lincoln well you
can't recreate the country and you can't
have the Civil War so what do you do
next he aspired to be James Monroe I
don't know but what you can do is you
can aspire not to be James pecan what
number of President was James Buchanan
what number in order he was the 15th and
before we go and try that when were you
born
where was that born I was born in Philly
and he was from Lancaster about 60 miles
away when was the first time you went to
his grave or his home I did a story for
the Philadelphia Inquirer weekend
section on what you can do in Lancaster
for you know if you went to the there
for the weekend it's also part of the
Amish country and I took my daughter who
was in high school so it's not that long
ago really she said she's a senior in
college now so maybe five years ago will
you give a lot of credit in your book
guy named Patrick Clark there's a great
quote in era but Patrick Clark and what
he says about James Buchanan would what
who is he Patrick Clark is sort of the
keeper of the goods there he's the guy
who runs Weakland Buchanan's home that
he bought when he was middle-aged and
lived in the rest of his life it's a
beautiful home if you go to wigglin just
if you like historic homes with period
furniture it's great too but he was
really helpful to me now he knew I was
not writing the most favorable biography
of Buchanan and we spent hours together
and what's funny about it is he sort of
acknowledges that began is not the
greatest president of the world but you
can once again he said the mindset you
can learn from anything what what does
he do I mean what's his job he runs
Wheatland the estate and sort of the
Buchanan legacy who supports it I
believe it's a private foundation but
it's Lancaster history it's all it's all
tied in there patty Stevens also came
from Lancaster and and there's other
historic monuments in and around there
I want to dip into your book and have
you tell the story
somebody this is a non sequitur but this
story was so unusual Daniel sickles oh
it's a great story but it's great about
history and of course you can view many
historians is that we forget it I mean
even even people who are relatively
interested in high school or college to
go through Washington found in the
country Jefferson Declaration of
Independence Lincoln freed the slaves
you know CEO you remember one thing of
everything but we forget that there's no
use in years years pass and many things
happen well Daniel sickles was a
congressman from New York but what he
was prior that he was when Buchanan was
ambassador to England he was his
right-hand man just before they left
sickles was in his early 30s he married
a fifteen year old woman in Washington
and got her pregnant
and then left England going to England
he took a prostitute with him a famous
prostitute I don't know how famous
prostitutes were but but he even
introduced a report anyway they time
passes he comes back he's gotten various
jobs in the government here and he he
gets a letter from somebody saying that
his wife was having an affair with
Philip key though pity was Francis Scott
Key's son everybody's related and
there's only 23 million people in this
country and not very many of them are of
the elite anyway so Philip Philip II is
also said to be the handsomest widower
in in Washington well anyway at some
point he sees Philip T in the park near
where he lives
it's a lot in part it was it was another
part nearby but he runs to Lafayette
Park he runs after him their life be
apart he starts running away and he
shoots and kills him right there in
front of everybody
however many people were there he runs
to the house of the Attorney General and
surrenders
so they lock him up but he's sort of
freer than many people and he gets to
meet with dignitaries in the wardens
lounge and one of those dignitaries is
the sitting president James Buchanan now
who can imagine the president going to
see somebody in jail like that but he
did anyway he secures as his defense
attorney Edward Stanton who Edward Stein
who eventually becomes Secretary of War
under Lincoln now he's gone to the ages
as his great quote when Lincoln dies and
he tries a new kind of defense called
the insanity defense
he gets sickles off sickles gets taken
from the courtroom on the shoulders of
his friends he has it he reconciles with
his wife he becomes a general at
Gettysburg ambassador to France as a
distinguished career of woods till he's
90 he gets the Medal of Honor
yeah the world in Civil War right so he
originally went to Great Britain as an
aide to James not exactly at what point
would James you Canon the ambassador the
minister to Great Britain in her life
well here's here's the thing about
Buchanan he's the most in a certain
sense qualified man by virtue of a
government resume to ever run for
president he was a he was a state
legislator in Pennsylvania than he was a
in the US House he was in the US Senate
he was ambassador to Britain under
Pierce prior to that he was ambassador
to Russia under Jackson as Secretary of
State under pulk
so he had a long and an overly quote
distinguished made a long career in
government service pretty unusual and so
he he was ambassador to Britain and not
a particularly crucial time but you know
he was that now how did what have you
done in your life when what was your
career my career I was I went to a small
school in Minnesota Carleton College of
major in philosophy which was a of
course great preparation become the
sports writer which is what I did I've
worked in newspapers magazines and
television
and at some point I decided to freelance
about 20 years ago when I teach writing
a nonfiction writing a pen so but but as
an adjunct not as a as a full-time
staffer and so it worked out pretty well
you were teaching when you discovered
that a president had gone to the
University of Pennsylvania who was that
yeah William Henry Harrison I was
teaching his classes and I was at fund I
said oh well you know you guys aren't
like Harvard Yale no presidents from
Penn this girl pipes up says here
president antenna said you talked about
says William Henry Harrison and I said
really
so we look up and so Harrison Harrison's
father whose name was Benjamin Harrison
as was his grandson who became president
was a siren Declaration of Independence
so he's been in Philly a lot even there
was from Virginia and he said and
William Henry Harrison wants to become a
soldier and his father says no you're
not you're going to go study medicine
with my friend Benjamin Rush up in
Pennsylvania Benjamin Rush started the
first hospital in America Pennsylvania
Hospital so it goes up you know
reluctantly he studies start studying
medicine at what titular leap end and
month or two into that this father dies
he says goodbye to Benjamin Rush and
goes back to Virginia becomes a soldier
so he's a small small case of attend
president you say and you have this you
just went through this
tik-tok list in the beginning of what
James G cannon has done in his life that
he ran for president how many times he
he was a serious kind of president three
times prior to becoming the actual
candidate in 1856 it was theater pretty
now he was always at the top echelon but
never you know the cliche that
bridesmaid never the bride
there was always somebody else who had
the ear of the the bureaucracy or
whatever you want to call it that runs
the party but eventually in 1856 he's
the last man left standing and
the sixteenth Balaton in Cincinnati
he becomes the Democratic nominee in
what I would say is about well the the
recent elections hold no candle to 1856
election which is transformational in a
way why okay the in 1853 we had a
president from the Whig party Norwood
Fillmore he he succeeded on the death of
Zachary Taylor but there was still a
Whig Party by 1854 it had broken apart
they've lost 1854 election incredibly to
Franklin Pierce and they just broke
apart and they essentially became two
other parties the the know-nothing party
and to think that we had an election
were the people who were in it called
itself a know-nothing party sort of says
a lot and the Republican Party taken the
name taken from the Democrat Republicans
of Jefferson's time so the known of
things where they're big platform was
anti-immigration which of course sounds
familiar today except that they were
anti-catholic immigration they thought
the Pope was going to come over here and
I don't know take up a seat on the on
Capitol Street and but they were against
Irish and Germans taking our jobs they
didn't quite have a candidate but they
found one and no word Fillmore who
wanted Bentley back into the White House
now he never wrote a thing about being
anti-immigration or anti Catholic or
anything but he want to be back in the
White House so he took up their cause so
to speak and then the Republican Party
was mostly northerners I was entirely
northerners who sort of they didn't
necessarily believe that they brew
slavery should be abolished but it
shouldn't extend into the territories
and as you know we during those years
preceding we tripled the size of our
country so they were looking around for
a candidate and the obvious one was
William Seward who was a senator from
New York but he said sort of like wow
there's an
party he was a former Whig I don't know
I'll wait my time out this is not going
to really work out this year and so they
picked a celebrity John Fremont and he
served nothing more than a celebrity he
had been a military governor in
California for a little bit but
basically he was called the Pathfinder
he would he and Kit Carson mapped out
the West they had four or five
expeditions and he wrote a sort of dry
journal about all this but he had
married the 17-year old dull of
Washington Jessie Benton who was the
daughter of the longest standing senator
at that point Thomas Benton Democrat
from Missouri so she is sort of the kris
kardashian to his bruce jenner
she sees something in him she's going to
make him something so she cuts he's up
his journal she takes him around to all
of her father's friends in Washington
and it becomes what would today be a
best-seller and so he's suddenly a
celebrity and Republicans say well we
could touch our write to this guy and so
he's the man who runs for president
Republican party the word that popped
out at me that you ascribed to came to
Kenan was obliviousness yeah what were
you getting at well what as you guys
start somewhere when you're researching
something and so I started in the
Library of Congress to research this and
you know something you mess around on
the Internet and finally a page comes up
and it's a letter from Buchanan to
Lincoln presumably the only letter B
kind of never wrote to Lincoln
but in whether it's the only one it's
the most significant one to me because I
love the goofiness of history so it's a
letter written in October of 1861 after
Lincoln been in office a little bit the
Civil War started lots of fighting in in
Northern Virginia on the particular day
that the letter gets written so maybe
began to notice one of Lincoln's good
friends from Illinois who became a
senator from
bargain dies in battle the only sitting
congressman ever to die in battle as
most people know studied Lincoln mrs.
Lincoln was always prone to blue periods
probably was at this point but even if
she wasn't he's old he would deal
prepared for this a Wars going on he's a
little busy but this letter from
Buchanan says that he forgot a few books
in the White House could you get
somebody to return them to me I'm
thinking like oh my god you know like
like he's not even thinking is there any
letter to a rambling hyper him Lincoln
right and this is the less he's like the
first thing Lincoln should be worrying
about on this particular day you know
you talk about a party that you cannon
had when he was being considered for the
Supreme Court yeah he you know he he he
always waffled that was his big problem
that he waffled about everything and he
was walking about the Supreme Court
decision but he said he's known as the
best partier in Washington so he has a
great party with a celebrity chef for
everybody to come over and he keeps
giving so little parties to supplement
it but then he Andy decides he doesn't
want to be in the Supreme Court so in a
certain sense he's done all this for
nothing
where'd he get the money to put on party
he was a good lawyer he was he was early
on he was a star student at Dickinson he
got thrown out for a while they let him
back in Dickinson College in
Pennsylvania and but he was always a top
student and he was always very sure of
himself and he goes to Lancaster because
it was then the the capital Pennsylvania
the largest england city in america
6,000 people Burke is pretty small so he
becomes the best lawyer there even
though the capital moves to Harrisburg
he decides to stay in Lancaster he he
defends a lot of people of note and he
makes a good book you say he also is
very generous with his nieces nephews he
was it be violated he ever marry he
never married there's a you know there's
always there's the speculation of
whether he was gay or not but
but early on there's a sort of an
amazing story to that how did we not
know this well he gets engaged to his
friends the wife's cousin Ann Coleman
her father was one of the richest men in
America he was an iron maker it was an
older man this was his youngest daughter
not excuse me is next to the youngest
daughter but you know he was very he
looked after her very well it didn't
sort of a proof of this relationship
that he was having with Buchanan but you
know let it go at some point Buchanan
comes home from Philadelphia where he
done some business steps up with his
friends house his friend's wife's cousin
is there apparently beautiful woman he's
there for an hour - he goes off of
course gossip goes around Lancaster this
level and Coleman accuses him of who
knows what she's accusing him of breaks
up the engagement sends him in the
bricks off the engagement
Buchanan doesn't know quite what to do
he serves Stan's magnets as well if I
were to go for a couple of weeks it'll
all blow over in that interim time she
goes off with her younger sister to see
her older sister in Philly they get to
Philadelphia she doesn't feel well the
other two go out to the theater by the
time she comes they come back she's in
convulsions and she dies presumably
suicide at least that sort of the
speculation that she killed herself over
this relationship now working out so
whether she killed herself or not the
idea that that a guy who eventually runs
for president has his fiancee dying when
he's young has to be sort of a big big
story somewhere now why did it man the
cover the book shows us why did you name
this book worst period president period
ever period well of course I have to bow
to my my editor who was one who thought
of the title it's it's sort of the way
people young people punctuated their
stuff now to to have these great pauses
in the way they think that they talk so
if you said worst person ever fast
somehow it doesn't have the resonance of
it
worse you know emphatic and I did really
want to make a point about how we rate
things have a great presence and how we
rate things in general in in our
discourse how do we we do everything you
know we have their polling has become
ubiquitous people pull everything about
everybody I mean you didn't have to end
up to watch the last election closely to
know that every day there was some new
poll coming out and and we became
interested in and that became the the
topic of the day who was ahead how many
points this state that state you know
their basketball polls and football post
based apply I point out you know each
week on Monday morning there comes out
to college basketball polls and you know
people they move up and down however the
teams do win or lose but at the end of
the season there is a 68 team tournament
that decides everything you don't need
these interim pulse because in the end
you're going to get the champion but yet
my kids went to or graduated from
Davidson College and their serve always
on the fringe at the bottom and if they
make it up to like twenty-fourth one day
I'll give a little cheer and I'll email
my wife and my kids and I'll gloat over
there beating who knows George
Washington or something so it's so we
were just we're just insane about rating
things and presidents are no different
so let's pick five you pick five and
presidents that you could put on the
bottom besides mccannon okay and and in
the book I do try to make a case for
Buchanan against these people some my
next the worst and I assure you I'm not
going to write a book about him as the
second worst president would be his
predecessor Franklin Pierce who did
virtually every stupid thing that
Buchanan did I insisted we but but bad
decisions except the Civil War did not
start on his watch he was able to
forestall that so even just for that one
thing he sort of rates ahead lots of
people of course will pick Herbert
Hoover who
the Great Depression started under but
Hoover made great attempts to to
ameliorate it they weren't successful
but he was he had ideas and he was
really trying to do something buchanan
the great fault was he he stepped back
and if my name time use should be
stepping forward he would step back so
Hoover at least tried to do things he
brought some good people in the
government he he did he forced old any
any hostilities I realized that
Mussolini and Hitler were sort of moving
along the line as he was as he was
president but but he was able to see our
way through Pierce a piece that Pierce
another person that people dick the
contemporary would be Jimmy Carter I
never put Carter at the bottom of a list
first of all he he negotiated the only
Middle East peace settlement that really
still exists between Israel and Egypt he
he brought consciousness to to
environmental situation he people left
them wearing sweaters but that was you
know at least there was some sort of
consciousness of that he had a bad
economy he certainly screwed up in Iran
but but and he had you know a marvelous
post presidency so I couldn't pick him
Richard Nixon it depends on what you
think if you think that that having to
resign in disgrace is worse than
starting the civil war
well then I can't argue with you but
also Nixon did a number of things that
have lasted opening China starting the
EPA so so he has his good qualities too
and I guess that if I've already done
five this is the six but it
Warren Harding people talk about but one
of the things about Warren Harding is he
came to the presidency wanting to
continue the business the the good
business cycle that had started and he
was able to do it he their skin was an
administration he had an illegitimate
child but and he died in office but
still he did what he said he was going
to
do which is at least something so how
did you decide to write this book then
about the worst president in history in
your mind okay well part of it is this
whole thing of like my father and doing
me the presidents and I'm thinking about
him and and I play early-morning
basketball in Philadelphia I I park it
5:30 or 6:00 in the morning on a certain
street corner and it's a notorious
street corner in Philadelphia and we'll
get into why but but it is and but on
the corners this that's amazing
historical societies where many of them
speak Lenin's papers are I think mmm you
know James Buchanan I hadn't really
thought all that much about him but but
then I went concerns study the papers I
see like you know like he made this
decision medicine they're all bad
decisions and I thought who said so oh
look of course me but but there were
decisions that led to the civil war in a
sense I mean it there was a there's a
clear pathway of sort of almost they
were almost non decisions in some ways
why are the papers where you found them
what were his nephew what many of his
papers there you know is it
what'd one of his he was very right as
you said very conduits nieces and
nephews and his nephew took charge of
many of his papers and when he died he
left them to thee had you written books
before I read I mom a journalist I've
written a lot of stories my but I
written one book before and it was a
memoir about being the dad of girl
athletes but it wasn't like my kids were
the greatest it was sort of funny and
sentimental and so it was a completely
different kind of thing than this you
say that jamesu cannon did not profit
financially
now we well he was he he he was in his
mind independently wealthy he was not
the wealthiest man in America but but
his desires were to give parties he
loved giving parties there's always a
positive aspect to every negative guy
and he was
two things about him is one in all this
papers never had a lot of stuff by him
about him to him he never says anything
bad about anybody publicly at least in
Houston papers I don't know what he said
hit you in verbal terms but he even
people he didn't like politically he
never said anything bad about them
personally and like I said he loved
giving parties and he was the inaugural
ball of 1857 was the greatest party in
nineteenth-century America how did you
find that okay well here's the problem
after Van Buren the next several
presidents had non partying aspects to
them Washington wasn't very big town but
they're still in Italy party scene it
would have been Dolly Madison was
certainly invited every party so after
Van Buren William Henry Harrison dies
after a month in office the successor
John Tyler has a sickly wife she dies
while he's in office not much partying
going on there Pope comes in his wife's
a strict Presbyterian no drinking of
dancing in the White House not much
partying going on there
next president Zachary Taylor he dies in
office Millard Fillmore comes into
office his wife is sickly she dies soon
after his term is over but but you know
there's no first lady than partying
going on she really wants to recede in
the background and the most tragic of
all is Franklin Pierce - he was said to
be the handsomest president he was he he
was sort of the John Kennedy of his time
young president picked out of nowhere
from New Hampshire his his wife doesn't
want to believe New Hampshire but yet he
runs and wins he has two sons who died
young and then he has a third son is of
course is now favorite son as he's sort
of taking his victory lap after winning
on the train he's in Massachusetts that
train as an accident his son dies in
front of him and his wife
so the third son dies but really misses
mrs. Peirce wears black - the whole time
of his presidency she barely ever
appears in public
so we have this whole a long time of no
parties in Washington Sun made the great
part of your James be cannons the
president he gives this fantastic
inaugural ball he put something they put
up a huge ten eleven square six thousand
people come now six thousand people
alive in a country that only had 23
million people and then star-spangled a
big Orchestra food the can imagine
saddles of this and oysters like that
and Harriet Lane his niece is the first
lady and she is the Jackie Kennedy of
her time she's every everything she
wears all the young women one aware they
have trading cards that are Harriet Lane
trading cards they name a Coast Guard
Cutter after the USS Harriet Lane it
eventually fires the first shot of the
Civil War from the Union side it gets
captured by the Confederates they don't
we name it she's too popular it's still
that a you it's still the CSA or
whatever they would have CSS a Harriet
Lane so so these two together are just
looked upon he starts out in such a
favorable way all the dignitaries come
that's the story the recounting of it in
the New York Times and other papers are
just wonderful they're just a wonderful
wonderful written story about the
pomping and everything that is going
from Washington but then the Dred Scott
decision comes down before we get there
okay
why is Harriet Lane known as the first
first lady okay they sort of called
Dolly Madison that the first lady
because she was so prominent in society
both while she was first late for law
she was the the president's wife and
then afterwards in the after Madison's
death she was the go-to person every
party dolly had to be at but then
Harriet Lane is the hostess in the White
House so what are you going to call her
she's not the president's wife she's
president's niece so they called her the
first lady
so if you go back over as you suggest
James you can is life he was a state
senator or repin Pennsylvania Ava state
rep right state house okay yeah the law
degree he goes on to be a congressman to
the US Congress from Pennsylvania he
becomes a senator from there he becomes
the minister to Russia the minister to
Great Britain and secretary of state
senator and Secretary of State and then
becomes president is he at that point
the most qualified person to be
President ah if you if that's what you
go by yes if you go by the number of
years had a major post and depending on
what you call major posts he definitely
is but here's something about him he
never proposed any significant
legislation or he never got any
significant legislation passed he was a
conciliatory man he was that's why he
was probably he was extremely good in
Russia Andrew Jackson sent him to Russia
and is said to have said on his deathbed
that he would have sent him further if
he could he didn't particularly like be
kind of but he was sort of the Don
Corleone iam presidency was micromanaged
everybody and made sure that everybody
would would cling to him so so he kind
of comes to office with a long resume he
was sort of boring to people he was 65
when he was elected nobody until Reagan
was that old after him and the Democrats
had had quite a streak in the White
House after the first two Federalists
they won 10 to the next 13 elections he
was a Democrat he's a Democrat you know
pretty good 10 of 13 few ball teams
instead of 13 you're pretty happy so he
comes to office is a crucial time but it
doesn't seem any more crucial than
Pierce's term or Fillmore's term slavery
is the overhanging problem what the
first day that he is president okay he
becomes president March in March as they
did then instead of January the year the
year in 1857 and so so he sees
his mandate to solve the slavery
question it's not get rid of slavery the
subs neighbor has a question he was
called though face which was a southern
leaning northerner they said he could
you know massage their faces like dough
and but he lived in Washington
Washington was a southern city I mean he
was a bachelor he went back to
Pennsylvania but most of the time he's
in Washington
his friends were southerners because
more southerners and northerners
actually took up residence in Washington
the railroads got the northerners back a
lot easier so he's pretty supposed to
think like his friends anyway so he
wants to sell the slavery problem to
keep the Union together and he sees this
court case going around it's called the
Dred Scott case Dred Scott was a slave
to a military man Missouri who for a
time went to what is now Minnesota free
territory and then came back to Missouri
he dies Dred Scott sued saying I was
free in Minnesota I should be free like
I say the court case goes around and it
comes up that it could be on the Supreme
Court's docket but Roger 20 the Supreme
Court Chief Justice who like Buchanan
with the Dickinson College so they had
some sort of bond you say he did not own
slaves I kind of did not 20 did Tony did
on strike sounds like many I don't know
how many but enough him yeah whether
what you call many but but he had slaves
his whole life he was from Maryland and
he was Francis Scott Key's
brother-in-law too sure that everybody's
very connected
sorry wait so they have this discussion
before Japan takes office and says we
can't just have a decision that's
southern northern the court was split
five southerners and four northerners
it's not going to amount to much you so
be kind takes upon himself to find
northern justice that will go along with
this and he finds a guy named Robert
story who
coincidentally enough went to Dickinson
College so they have this bond once
again and story says okay I'll go along
with whatever 20 does and another
northerner from New York says they'll
write a concurring opinion so it's
essentially seven to two now you can
have a decision that might mean
something
northerners going on with southerners
the decision comes out two days after
the inauguration it said that on the
inaugural platform before Tony gives us
him the oath that they discussed
something Buchanan had distributed
souvenir transcripts of his inaugural
address there are a few lines that
weren't in it and a few lines sort of
allude to this decisions going to come
out we're going to all be happy about it
but the Dred Scott decision has
generally thought of as the worst
decision that the Supreme Court has ever
made their contenders for that too but
in any case it essentially says that
every state is a slave state it says
that Dred Scott can't sue in court he's
not a free man
he's therefore can't sue in fact he's
still a slave and in fact slavery can't
be outlawed by individual states it
reinstitute the most heinous parts of
the Fugitive Slave Law and agates all
the compromises from before all the ones
who remember from high school Missouri
Compromise compromised 1850 and
essentially makes the united states of
slave country but right away you say
there's something called the panic of
1857 right so what this causes we've had
a 20-year expansion things have been
going great countries opening up we said
a purchase Oregon Territory Texas all
these other lands that we're getting
people have the American dream going on
you don't make it in Pennsylvania go up
to Ohio go up the Illinois go up to
Missouri wherever you can make it
railroads
finance this essentially people
speculate on different railroads but
suddenly this decision comes out and
let's say you've got a tin cup factory
in Cincinnati going pretty well maybe
he'll open one and date
uh-oh maybe this guy's going to come up
with Kentucky from Kentucky with its
slaves and being my competitor so I
don't do anything I stopped I stopped
expanding the country immediately stops
expanding people who have speculated on
railroads railroads aren't doing so well
immediately they go bankrupt the you
know take a ride on the reading like in
in the Monopoly game reading railroad
stops running that other businesses fail
so within months we're in this
tremendous economic panic a greater
precipitous depression than the Great
Depression all the banks in New York
closed for a day they decide not to take
script well you don't have sort of gold
scraping it off of that to pay your
employees of the tin cup Factory but in
the south it doesn't affect them that
much as much because they're an
agricultural society you can feed and
clothe your your family at the very
least you can probably sell your your
cotton in your your lima beans but in
the north or manufacturing is cotton
sway it's really precipitous so that
divides the country over more how would
it compare panic of 1857 with our
problem in this country in 2007 because
was so because because the the money
class was so much smaller and they were
affected so much so greatly so quickly
so that our most recent recession I'm
not belittling it was not as like this
it's not a it's not a dive off of a
cliff it was it was sort of a slower and
things things happened in a matter of
course as opposed to just precipitously
I'll give you one example I like to tell
stories within this it that have
something to do with me but I'm I'm out
looking for a 25th anniversary present
for my wife
yeah I'm trying to think of goofy things
so I go to this coin store thing I'll
get a quarter 25th right quarter or I'll
get some you know silver dollar from
when we were married but I'm waiting for
my turn and I look in the case and
there's people who look at coins know
that
once again big when in the 18 in the
19th century some will give these coins
and then suddenly in 1857 coins are like
this like a dime sansa guy says Oh panic
of 1857 that was be cannons great idea
we'll make the coin smaller well that's
about his idea because the rest of his
idea is like near the heck with you you
speculated you deserve it why don't you
be like the people in the South who work
hard with their hands so he does nothing
to Milly rate it he says figures it's
going to play itself out and sure enough
it does because eventually we have a lot
of munitions to make in 1861 you say
that Americans have a lot of vitriol
toward their presidents yeah I think so
I I don't know how you feel or people
file out their feel but you probably
don't hate their mayor or congressmen
they might not agree with them in this
era you know like something like that
but especially as the less election
shows there you know where the the it
can only go by polls how much the two
main candidates were disliked as opposed
to light and I don't think that's any
different from times in the past we tend
to have must because they're the top
person that you know whatever it's
jealousy or we feel they have the
ultimate say over us and we can't
possibly agree with everything they say
and somehow we really find like to say
vitriol I know you wrote about James J
cannon but if you had to say the four or
five most interesting presidents that
you've looked at studied gone to their
sites over your years who would they be
interesting not success right right
right I you know it's funny I I did
write a story for the New York Times
once on visiting a site of lesser-known
presidents of course I knew the kind of
book was coming so I put him at the top
of story but I found that as I look into
the lesser-known presence I was sort of
more interested in them
my core which is an interesting
character even it really you know this
whole silent Cal thing one of the things
in my little statistical book was he had
three hobbies one was pitching hay one
was riding a mechanical horse and one
was throwing Indian clubs and then like
really like yes like who who knew they
threw Indian clubs but in any case
they're like bowling pins so so so I
always found these these sorts of people
interesting badger my wife to stop the
presidential sites we she we we live in
New Jersey we drive out to her mother's
house in Michigan and on the Ohio
Turnpike we would pass this sign
constantly mother Phoebe Hayes's house
saying one day I'm going to go there one
day I'm going to go there finally we're
driving out last year and I say can we
please go there and she looks at me and
she says ninety minutes I got 90 minutes
to cover brother for da so we go to his
house it's a beautiful house thirty some
rooms as his father died and his uncle
was rich and and and built this house
for his mom and him and anyway we're
going through it and of course there's
only two other people on the tour it's
not a presidential history is fine but
most people stick with Monticello Mount
Vernon and so at the end of the tour the
the woman says would you like to see
Hayes's bellows driven harpsichord have
like Indian clubs what the belt is
German arms Accord so I said of course
and she brings it out and service as you
might imagine it's driven by the Bellas
at the bottom and she says we'd like to
play it and it was like well yeah and
Mozart's why I went to so for me that's
like wonderful so I go and I pump this
thing at the bottom and I play take me
out to the ball game and I'm just
imagining Hayes sitting there saying
yeah let's go let's play too
you know what are some of the other
presidents that day you know you put on
the list if you're going to be a visitor
I would say well of course the great
ones you know you would you know I don't
care how different their politics are
yours but come on you know you know
George Bush has the same birthday as me
the younger George Bush I'm waiting for
him to invite me to his birthday party
I mean I'm age now he's five years older
than me
exactly Merv Griffin also had the same
birthday so unfortunately he's not
around but if he were we could play
jeopardy together because and submerse
invented but but I would like to meet
all of them III did it one I went to the
story with David Eisenhower Ike's a
grandson who's writing books about his
grandfather's time he was a Pulitzer
finalist for one of them so the penile
um night magazine 10:00 he teaches a pen
David close Marilyn says really write a
story wait a minute I might I'm thinking
like God you know eyes now isn't it so
not all that well thought of and instead
of the schema presence but so he starts
telling me stories about a man and and
once he starts telling me stories I said
well David's father the middle
generation was Ike's chief of staff and
they eventually retired at Gettysburg so
David I don't know young teenager less
than teenager and I could come to his
little games
now if you imagine that the president
coming to Scranton throw away games so
wouldn't when you want to sit with Ike
and talk baseball and I said that must
have been a lot of pressure David said
oh no I'll tell you what pressures says
you know my grandfather loved to play
golf and so that was a one time he will
allow the press to come and take
pictures is on the tee when he would
invite some general or you know diplomat
or something fidelity and often there
would only be two other guys so it's a
daily come on you got to come out and
play says that's pressure all the
nation's cameras are on me a 14-year old
trying to make a good drive so you know
the more you know about these people you
know that they were substantial people
even if they I mean I always said I've
always said have been modest people who
always want to say how dumb George Bush
was or something tonight wait a second
this guy went to Yale and Harvard
Business School you might not agree with
his politics but he's not dumb and and
so I would I'd love that
dinner with any of what could our new
president learn from studying pet a pet
sleep educator that's it problem yeah by
presenting James you can okay he could
do I think the differentiation of good
presence in bed presidents you know
Washington Lincoln and FDR always at the
top of the the surveys that historians
take they were decisive men you can't
come to the top of the ladder and not be
decisive Buchanan was a waffler James
Polk hated him for being a wobbler as
Secretary of State he always went back
and forth on decisions they you're my
advise you gotta tell me what to do so
that's how he was as president I could
go on the list of things that make him
the worst president and all of them have
to do with not making a decision when he
had to make a decision so that's what
the next presidents whether it's this
president or or or succeeding presidents
should learn he some point you got to
say this is the way it's going to be I
mean people who didn't like Reagan don't
understand the reason why people liked
him is because he made decisions
whatever they were so go a different
deal through a couple of decisions he
did not make that led to the Civil War
okay so there's that so that the next
upcoming state is going to be Kansas
Kansas has a problem is it going to be
free
coming free or Slade so the slave
contingent comes over from Missouri
makes a capital and LeCompte in a small
town chins up a constitution that allows
slavery so non slave people come to
Topeka they have a similar
Constitutional Convention just the
opposite of course there that there
there were six slaves and all of Kansas
at the time it's not like it's going to
be slave territory but the South needed
another slave state they needed somebody
on their side so of course they're
supporting a special team of Missouri
something's got to happen we can it's
got to say something he's got to choose
one of the other he's got to have a
something he's got to say there's got to
be an election there's got to be
something that
going to resolve this problem he caught
it before it becomes a problem but then
of course he does he makes no decision
he sends several people out there to be
governors of Kansas he doesn't listen to
any of them saying this very thing
they're not that many soldiers in the
United States is only about 12,000
troops one of the things that happens in
this in this Maelstrom is people start
firing each other John Brown who becomes
much being this later more famous later
he's said to have murdered several slave
owners and their families
now it's called bloody Kansas but still
be cannon makes no decision Brown gets
away it's not like he was doing things
in secret he meets with Harriet Tubman
and and and Frederick Douglass and other
anti-slavery people eventually comes to
Harpers Ferry in 1859 well in 1813 you
go to now to bucolic setting Appalachian
Trail goes through it it looks like a
Disney version of the 19th century
village the back then it was a big
munitions maker other industry it was 40
miles down the road from Washington
Brown comes their not so foolish if he
can get some of these munitions gather
some more people on those cause maybe he
can have this slave rebellion that he
wants for two days Buchanan does nothing
nothing he says and let them handle it
in Virginia it was part of Virginia West
Virginia then until this prominent scion
robert e lee comes home from his post in
texas to Arlington he goes to Buchanan
says no I think we ought to do something
he says all right take take some troops
out there see we could do of course we
does capture Brown they have a service
shuttle trial he eventually gets hang
but by this time he is a martyr victor
hugo's writing about him wealth Waldo
Emerson and his crew were writing about
Walt Whitman's writing about him now and
of course that angers both
besides exacerbating any problem there
is because of his inaction when the
Corcoran Art Gallery shut down here in
Washington they had to get rid of a lot
of paintings you say in your book that
the National Gallery of Art refused to
take the Buchanan painting not by George
Healey yeah well here's the problem of
course one of one of the great things
about how are you Lena said into her
dotage she was the go-to woman for every
party in Washington - she in doubt went
to her son's dai-chien down at Johns
Hopkins Children's Lab still his
research lab which is still in her name
and she has this art collection some of
which is Buchanan art and she gives it
to start a National Gallery of Art she
essentially started the National Gallery
board and one of course our favorite
paintings was this portrait of her uncle
and ironically enough when they
dispersed the art yeah this particular
portrait of the founders uncle who's
president doesn't make it into cut give
any idea why probably a very good
painting but but but but it went into
sort of a portrait section of a lesser
gallery so so when you you dedicate the
book to your father and mother and for
your father for making a read all the
roadside nice to article signs what when
you think is your father alive now is
that when you think back about your dad
in those early days how old were you in
those early days when you first started
fooling around with history and what do
you remember an incident or two with
your father
well it's a I was about five or six but
we didn't travel much and said what'd he
do
oh he was a lawyer who's a local lawyer
in Camden New Jersey and but he was
still fascinated with history we haven't
I still have my books and books and
books like president Pope's letters or
all these third things so they were
always around but we did take one trip
to the South when I was ten it was 1961
and and we started going to Civil War
sites because I was starting the Civil
War Centennial
but we made it to Staunton Virginia
where Woodrow Wilson's birthplaces and
we'd come up to the door and there's a
sign that it's closed and that's lolly
you know we never traveled there looks
around and it was the day that second
mrs. Wilson died like how unlucky could
we possibly be but we've anniversary
meet is called Wilson's death no it was
the day she died oh that's how did you
think about the other one right yeah
okay so so it's like who could pick that
day but anybody services and you dress
it up and you sides and we're going to
go to Charlottesville not very far away
but we don't go to Monticello first or a
salon where we're James Monroe lived we
go to the library at the University of
Virginia he storms up the stairs even
the chubby small guy and my mother waits
in the lobby because she's already
rolling her eyes and I go up with him
he's got this old box camera he comes up
to the librarian I don't think there's
anybody there as I remember and he says
I'm Judge Strauss from New Jersey and
I'm friends with judge he makes up a
name in Virginia and he says I want to I
need to photograph Thomas Jefferson's
will all right so the guy's saying no no
no you can do that we can bring it down
finally my father's berating this guy
mentioning this judge in Virginia who
I'm sure is apocryphal and he finally
gets and finally gets the guy to go
cowering back and brings out the pages
of Jefferson's Willie photographs them
and he frames them in three frames and I
know it's three frames because when he
died I definitely had to help them in my
office I'm this framed Jeffersonian will
in my office so so that's sort of how
yeah that's a hell on the view and
that's why I want to tell sort of fun
stories of history so go back to your
and the brother Behe's home and your
wife says ninety minutes over time
you've been married how long now 1989 to
27 years so over time what's her
attitude then about your obsession with
presidents she sorta doesn't mind it
because she had a fellowship at Stanford
and we drove across the country and of
course Herbert Hoover is well known at
Stan
there's a Hoover Institution and and he
went there but on the way we go through
Iowan we go through West Branch Iowa and
we stopped at Herbert Hoover's childhood
farm and now we run to the chicken coop
and we look at the cats and so you know
she finds her her you know side
enjoyments in my you know bizarre nature
of looking at history I make kids we
have two kids Ellen's lvl is 25 Sylvia's
21 both went to Davidson where for only
a short time as it says it is historical
marker when you go there Boudreau Wilson
attended Davidson for one year what are
your kids going of all this history
stuff well you know they they would
pretend not to be like me but I know
that that Sylvia the younger one
especially sort of loves the nuances of
history in Ellis studied history
although mostly Indian in India meaning
the country of India history so they
they sort of look upon it assembly I
think about out of time but what are the
chances I can get you to write a book on
Dan sickles and sickles oh I know when
Miranda has got to set a ham open he's
got to have sickles when you think who's
your favorite character with last
question in this whole book oh well I
think it's got to be Harriet Lane that
the niece of the president that I never
knew about that was this joint in most
one of the most popular women in
Washington for half a century it would
be the other thinking of musical Robert
Strauss our guest the book is called
worst president ever the POTUS rating
game the legacy of the least of the
lesser residents presidents excuse me
James Buchanan among them on the cover
there thank you very much for joining us
thanks for having me